c'est ici sur cette parcelle du
sud-ouest de la forêt de dreux que s'est
écrasé le 5 juillet 1944
le bombardier américain lady godiva à
son bord six soldats américains et
d'angleterre c'était des bombardiers
lourds qui venait donc du nord et qui
survolait est passé au dessus au dessus
de la forêt direction le poteau 75 ans
plus tard une équipe du pentagone est
missionné en eure et loir
sur les traces de ses soldats disparus
elle est guidée par le directeur
départemental de l'office national des
forêts en trois jours près de 80
hectares ont été passés au peigne fin
cinq personnes sont arrivées de cette
agence il y avait deux historiens un
docteur qui est anthropologue et
archéologue et puis deux personnes dont
un interprète pour nous questionner et
procéder aux recherches nous ont
retrouvé des traces effectivement de
métal mais surtout des traces de sorgues
d'aviateur donc qui avait brûlé et pour
accéder à ces vestiges de l'histoire
américaine
le pentagone a fait appel à une équipe
de cette passionnée depuis 1996
l'association for splendide reconstitue
minutieusement l'histoire des soldats de
l'eure et loir pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale ils nous ont contactés afin de
savoir sur la mésinformation sur le
crash de ce bombardier en forêt entre
eux suite à ça on a fait quelques
investigations il n'a trouvé dans les
archives de la mairie d'abondants cet
acte qui dit que les allemands on
enterrait de corps suite au crash
l'équipe américaine doit revenir sur les
lieux dans les prochains mois pour mener
des fouilles plus précise et peut-être
levé le voile sur la mort des deux
soldats disparus du lady godiva